welcome to the Yale Law School
Auditorium to Yale University it's a
distinct honor today my name is Peter
Sullivan president of Yale and it's a
distinct honor to introduce our 2015
chub fellow President Obama's national
security adviser Susan Rice ambassador
rice we welcome you to Yale University
and we're so grateful for your
willingness to share your time and
insights with all of us we're delighted
that ambassador rice is joined today by
a member of her family who is also a
member of our family this is John rice
Yale College class of 1988 and a current
fellow of the Yale corporation before I
speak about our visitors I want to say a
few words about the history of the Chubb
fellowship so Hendon Chubb was in 1895
graduate of yells Sheffield scientific
school that's the precursor to the Yale
School of Engineering and Applied
Sciences in 1936 he made a substantial
gift to Yale University to encourage
students to take an interest in public
service since 1949 the Chubb endowment
has been used to underwrite prestigious
visiting speakers who would bring kind
of an extra extraordinary presences to
campus that would inspire our students
this Fellowship is administered by the
master of timothy dwight college
Marylou past Chubb fellows have included
four presidents of the United States
presidents of eight other countries and
more than 150 other regional national
and internationally prominent
individuals noted for their distinction
in service to the common good
the annual Chubb lecture is a wonderful
opportunity to reinforce the shared
values of our community
and I know it's a special treat today
for you all to hear from someone who is
serving at the very heart of our nation
and our national interest as National
Security Advisor ambassador rice
oversees the National Security Council
staff chairs the national security
principles committee provides the
president's daily national security
briefing and is responsible for
coordinating the administration's
foreign policy intelligence and military
efforts she has held numerous
appointments within the National
Security Council including his Director
for international organizations and
peacekeeping as special assistant to
President Clinton and as Senior Director
for African affairs from 1997 to 2001
she was the u.s. Assistant Secretary of
State for African affairs and in 2000
she was Co recipient of the White
House's Samuel Nelson drew memorial
award for distinguished contributions to
the formation of peaceful cooperative
relationships between states as a senior
advisor for national security affairs in
the with the Obama for America campaign
she went on to serve as a member of the
advisory board for the obama-biden
transition and then as co-chair of its
policy working group on national
security from 2002 to 2009 she was a
senior fellow at the Brookings
Institution where she focused on u.s.
foreign policy transnational security
threats weak States global poverty and
development before her appointment as
national security advisor in 2013 she
served as the u.s. permanent
representative to the United Nations
where she worked to strengthen national
and global security and to promote human
rights ambassador Rice received her BA
in history from Stanford University she
holds an MPhil and DPhil and
international relations from new college
and Oxford University and she was a
Rhodes Scholar there
this is a remarkable opportunity for our
students not just to learn about issues
in national security but to learn about
a career path in public service that I
am sure is an inspiration I'm
particularly pleased that today's
lecture will actually take the form of a
conversation and it's a conversation
between ambassador rice and as I hinted
at earlier a member of the elk community
who is uniquely positioned to join her
here on stage why do I say that well
John rice Yale College a TA and a fellow
of the Yale Corporation is the founder
and CEO of management leadership for
tomorrow which is a nonprofit
organization that helps members of
underrepresented minority groups to
become leaders in the corporate
nonprofit and entrepreneurial sectors
after graduating from Yale with a degree
in Latin American Studies he earned his
MBA from the Harvard Business School and
while at Harvard he wrote a business
plan for his current organization and in
1994 he launched it and launched it via
a mentoring program for minority
undergraduates he was appointed to
President Obama's Advisory Commission on
educational excellence for
african-americans and has served as a
member of the president's Board of
Advisors on historically black colleges
and universities he also serves on a
number of nonprofit boards including
lift the national center for civil and
human rights the American Management
Association the Woodrow Wilson national
fellowship foundation as I mentioned he
is a member of the Yale corporation the
trustees of Yale University are
fiduciaries before that he was a member
of the University Council which the
Weiser e-group to the president but most
importantly for today's purposes he
holds a very special role and that is he
is ambassador Rice's brother
brother so so I would like you to join
me in thanking him for facilitating
today's conversation and to also join me
in extending a very long warm welcome to
Connecticut to New Haven to Yale
University to Ambassador Susan Rice
thank you
I feel like I need a phone book can you
all see me Johnny got all the height in
the family yeah she says that she likes
to say that I'm a younger brother
because she feels that she looks younger
so thanks for having us first of all and
I think we're gonna try to have some fun
over the course of the of the of the
hour here and as Peter said approach
this a little bit differently than
potentially some the pasture fellow
lectures but but what we'd like to do
and we again I'll say you know Susan and
I have had plenty of fireside chats over
the years but none in public so this is
the first time we've done this and bear
with us right so who knows where it will
go but we hope it will be instructive
and I think we'd like to structure it in
a way that was a little bit different
than if this were a you know if I were
someone like a real interviewer okay
someone who does this for a living who
happens you know and because I'm her
brother
hopefully we can we can push a little
bit further on some issues if she'll let
me get a little bit more personal and
and hopefully we'll keep it professional
and hopefully we'll still like each
other when we're done right so so we'll
the way the way we're gonna structure
this I mean in terms of the fireside
chat before we open it up for questions
from you all is we'll talk a little bit
about the core here you know sort of
foreign policy which is you know you're
living and breathing every day and then
I think we'd like to broaden it and talk
more generally about issues that I think
that I know that Susan cares about that
kind of cross they may they may
incorporate foreign policy but they may
be focused on other issues and and that
she thinks are important and want to
hear her thoughts and those few themes
there and then we want to give you more
personal and and give you all a sense of
what makes her tick and hopefully to
share some advice and perspective from
the you know the experiences that she's
had so that's gonna be the approach
obviously that will open up for
questions and we can go anywhere with
those questions as well okay Susan no no
this is something that you never done
she's never you know foreign some water
for me that's actually not true she's a
great cook and and she'd has over for
dinner on Sunday night and did a
fantastic job so appreciate that so
let's start foreign policy and we know
that she has a high-pressure job and to
say the least one of the highest
pressure pressure cooker jobs I think in
the world and so my first question
really is you know when describe a time
where you have been the most nervous all
right when we worried the most about
having to go do something before you did
it this is going to sound strange to
some of you but the work I do every day
in my job is work that I feel relatively
comfortable with and I've been doing it
for the better part of my career and I'm
a stress about issues or stress about
how a particular event or trip or visit
may come out but that's very normal
manageable stress for me the most
stressed I've ever been in life in all
honesty was when I had to throw out the
opening pitch at the Nationals game in
2013 I had just taken my job as national
security adviser that month I am a
decent athlete but I'm no particular
skill at baseball and I was determined
to throw it from the mound and at least
wanted to get it across in the vicinity
of the plate to the plate at least the
distance and I was practicing for weeks
really then
I was lucky enough that some of the guys
on my security detail were willing to
throw with me so we'd go out we'd throw
a few on a Saturday or Sunday and the
transition occurred right as I left my
job at the UN and was coming over to the
White House and my security detail
switched from Diplomatic Security that
helped me and took care of me when I was
a UN Ambassador to Secret Service and my
lead agent on Secret Service was
determined that I was not going to
humiliate everybody at the plate and so
he was kind enough to throw with me in
the tunnel right before I went out on
the field and I had to go out and I was
struck by how fast it all happened you
get there and they say okay go to the
mound and you 50,000 people are watching
you and you're either gonna get it or
you you're not going to get it and you
can imagine that you know I've been the
subject of a little bit of public the
racism on occasion and I could just see
Fox News you know doing a loop
on me grounding the ball you know so I
got up there and there was no time and
they said okay Susan writes the National
Security Adviser
Johnny was there and it was mostly
cheers there was some audible boos and I
just had to throw and I wound up and
threw it and I threw a strike across the
plate and my heart rate went from
probably 190 back down to something like
70 and Walker Bossip said it was a dirty
rag Don me until you know there was no
end and he had done the same and of
course manager threw a pitch so he would
have talked about me and then I was
worried frankly on behalf of all women
kind that you know if I let the side
down that it would have been terrible so
that was stress of a short I was not
accustomed to and I'm never ever doing
it again so so let's talk about a Syria
let's switch it a little bit that
stresses me out too so I know you share
with me like did that how you know this
is maybe the most complicated foreign
policy issue that you that you've had to
deal with intellectually in your career
in parts because you know it seems like
they're you know almost nothing but bad
options that cascade into another you
know set of worse options and even worse
scenarios and so forth so you know first
question sir is there is there any path
to a political solution and is there any
way that we can mitigate or alleviate
this humanitarian crisis that's coming
out of there
well honestly I do I do think that the
crisis in Syria is the hardest problem
to solve that I've encountered and I've
felt that way from the very beginning
four and a half years ago and it's only
getting harder there's no question I do
think there is a path to a political
solution and we're working very hard
towards that as we have for quite a
while but as the dynamics have changed
and the circumstances have evolved
in some ways the path is more fraught
when you consider that this is now a
multi-front conflict it's the opposition
against Assad Assad against the
opposition and his people
it's Itzel and al-nusra the al-qaeda
affiliate
against both of those sides and it's the
world against disel and al-nusra so it
is a mash-up if there is such a thing on
the battlefield and the only way this
gets resolved is through a political
solution there's no other way I mean you
could have local ceasefires conceivably
we have periodic success in humanitarian
access but to deal with the primary
concern we have which is defeating ISIL
and ensuring that the threat that that
very pernicious terrorist organization
poses is not exacerbated and and doesn't
reach our shores is our primary focus
but to accomplish that obviously we also
have to deal with the fundamental
underlying conflict which is a civil
conflict which has taken an
extraordinary humanitarian toll and we
obviously have a great interest in
alleviating the suffering and that war
can only end at the negotiating table
that's going to require a resolution not
frankly dissimilar from what was
envisioned back in Geneva in 2012 when
we were part of a negotiation that
established a framework that envisioned
a transitional governing authority
agreed by mutual consent between the
opposition and the government and the
theory of that was if there had to be
mutual consent there couldn't be the
perpetuation of the assad façades
leadership in a regime that had lost all
legitimacy with its people there would
have to be other elements from the
existing government that had less blood
on its hands in practice elements of the
opposition who were capable of bringing
expertise to a transitional governing
body and then a period of transition
time to be determined during which and
Constitution could be written elections
could be organized a ceasefire
implemented etc that still remains
fundamentally the the likeliest outcome
when eventually we get to a political
solution we are trying very hard to
accelerate the achievement of the
political solution and Secretary Kerry
last week met in Vienna with the foreign
ministers of Turkey and Saudi Arabia and
Russia who are key players obviously in
this and he will meet again in what I
expect would be just at several days
time with that group and then a broader
group of countries in the region with
the aim of trying to operationalize some
kind of political transition and
ceasefire the big thorny issue that
remains is is when and whether Assad
steps aside our view remains that he has
to go that there can't be an end to this
conflict which has taken so many lives
and cost caused so much suffering and
you know displacement of over four
million people without him departing as
part of the transition but at what stage
of the transition is something that is
being discussed and debated we have very
different views and our coalition
partners do from the Syrian government
the Russians and the Iranians but I
think there is the potential for an
arrangement to be agreed where in this
transition begins perhaps with Assad
still in power but that it doesn't end
with him in power and when along that
continuum the transition and his removal
occurs is is the hardest issue the other
challenge is frankly that the opposition
is extraordinarily fragmented and there
is no single group or leader that speaks
for those that have been fighting Assad
and now the opposition there is what we
believe to be or call and work with the
moderate opposition but they are
sometimes commingled with the extremist
opposition including elements like al
news
or those affiliated with al-nusra the
only thing that most people I would say
almost everybody agrees with is that it
so is a problem that that can only be
dealt with directly and
confrontationally and so the aim is to
get this political solution as soon as
possible and turn our collective efforts
without the distraction of the ongoing
civil conflict against disel right and
we haven't talked about Iraq but
obviously that's very much part of the
same whole right so so it's incredibly
complicated and I've been and if we so
for those of us who are not in there
with you and the president and secretary
Kerry and you're in your team's thinking
through these issues you know you know
I'm always I've always been curious sort
of you know what principles
human principles you kind of pull from
and whether they're you know beyond the
issues here is there anything that that
those of us who are not in your world
can glean about so what principles to
draw upon when you're dealing with a
situation where there are no good
options and you have to decide among
things about options that are you know
just that where you don't have a
positive set of options and I'm
wondering you know is there is there
anything that we can learn from again
outside of foreign policy in our own
lives
I mean thought you'd have on what
principles that you know what you've
learned what principles we can draw upon
that are relevant to to our lives
outside of your world I'm not sure if
the lessons are directly applicable and
in there in the world of foreign policy
and national security at the risk of
oversimplifying you know the first
question or the first principle that we
have to wrestle with is quite frankly
what is in the United States national
interest and that may be different the
answer to that question very ruthlessly
defined maybe not as edifying as we
might want to believe I mean in it is it
in the United States national interest
for example and
to get deeply involved in the conflict
on the ground in a combat role well
we've seen the consequences of the
conflict continuing that's a they are
deeply insidious consequences that are
have horrific outcomes for the people of
Syria are destabilizing given the
refugee outflow to the neighbors are now
having implications with the refugee
flow for Europe and now we have the
challenge of itsel which does directly
threaten our interests in that of our
allies and partners but we may have to
tailor our our solutions to more
narrowly to the challenge of defeating
ISIL than to the broader challenges that
are important that we care about but are
not the ones we must prioritize at the
same time we can we can alleviate
humanitarian suffering we are the
largest contributor to the humanitarian
response with over 4.5 billion dollars
but you know as human beings we all want
to to do what is you know the right
thing on a human level and sometimes
awesome time I would argue even
oftentimes what is right on a human
level is also what most or best serves
us interest but it's not a hundred
percent coincidence and sometimes the
hardest choices are when those things
can't be readily reconciled right so now
translating that into you know daily
life is is hard I mean when you face
circumstances where in your personal or
professional life you have no good
answers and and no good options you know
I think the I don't know that I can say
you know take this lesson from the
situation room and apply it somewhere
else but I think one thing I'd say is
you know when you examine your options
you have to ask not only what will be
the effect of a particular action but
you also have to ask what will be the
effective in action
yeah and weigh those and and try to
anticipate the consequences of your
actions you know three or four steps
down the road because what may be the
most immediate least bad answer today
could prove to be worse down the road
and and I suppose vice versa so in
trying to play out almost as if a chess
game the the actions and reactions is I
guess the the best analogy I can draw
that's help but it's it's it's hard to
it's hard to make a direct connection
I think that's instructive and and so
stepping back a little bit I mean you've
been on you've been a core member of the
president's foreign policy team from the
beginning right you started up at the UN
and now down in the White House and I
assume you're going to stay till the end
okay I haven't heard otherwise and so I
won't ask you know if you kind of
reflect back you guys a lot has been
accomplished you know what are you most
proud of you think about a couple you
know if you want to mention a few
milestones or a few accomplishments that
you're most proud of that you weren't
sure you could get done when you when
when when you join the team back
actually on the campaign and then and
when the president was sworn in and what
are you most proud of today well with
the caveat that that which I'm most
proud of doesn't mean that I had a
direct hand in okay
accomplishing all of them and I think
vitally important from a national
security point of view was the success
that our economic team had early on in
turning around the economy because a
huge source of our international
strength is the strength of our economy
domestically and whether we're able to
grow and produce wealth and jobs and
when the president came into office we
were as you well recall the the lowest
point since the Great Depression and now
after years we are back to a place of of
economic leadership in the world and the
rest of the world has
certainly made progress but you know
they're the economy's in in various
different parts of the world are still
relatively soft we are now not
impervious obviously but the strongest
link and that has been fundamental in
restoring our leadership abroad and but
beyond that obviously I mean we've tried
to focus on a number of things first of
all despite the the challenges that
still remain in Afghanistan and Iraq
when President Obama came into office we
had 180,000 troops and middle theaters
we are down to less than 10,000 in
Afghanistan today we'll be going down to
5,500 by the end of next year and we're
at about 3,300 in Iraq and very narrowly
tailored missions to supporting the
Iraqis and the Afghans by training and
advising and assisting them we're not in
combat in either theater directly
anymore and we're also can engaged in
counterterrorism in a targeted way I
think you know the the fact that we've
been able to redeploy and rebalance and
refresh our our armed forces is vitally
important to our readiness in our
ongoing strength even as the nature of
challenges has evolved but I'm
particularly pleased that when you look
around the world we're rebalancing to
Asia and the Asia Pacific a great deal
of our time and energy that doesn't get
a lot of attention in the press is
devoted to the work that we're doing in
the Asia Pacific we have just had over
the last several months high-profile and
very impactful visits from the Japanese
leader the Chinese leader the South
Korean leader just this week the
Indonesian leader we are heading to Asia
next month again we have gone if not
every year then twice every year in in
the recent past for very important
summit meetings out there and we've just
been able to conclude the trans-pacific
partnership trade agreement which is a
signature element of the Asia rebalance
so I think that's something the
we'll be of lasting significance we've
all worked very hard on the issue of
non-proliferation and trying to reduce
the threat from loose some people call
loose nukes which is not the term we're
supposed to use but you know we have
strengthened nuclear security in a very
meaningful way and then of course we've
been able to reach the agreement to
prevent Iran from obtaining a nuclear
weapon with the support of the
international community and I think that
will prove if fully implemented to have
been an unexpected and yet very
meaningful means of constraining a very
dangerous nuclear program and ensuring
that Iran is not able to obtain a
nuclear weapon so that that's another
thing I think frankly when we look back
on our time I certainly will be very
pleased that we've made an opening with
Cuba and that 50 years of failed policy
have been supplanted by what I think
will prove over the long term to be the
most effective means of opening up Cuba
both politically and economically and
finally and I could go on but you know
as a policy maker but also as a mother
and as a citizen you know one of the
issues that that I'm most concerned
about and I know the president has put
the highest priority on is climate
change and trying to address that threat
and we are now heading into Paris in
December for the cop meeting on climate
change with the real potential of
achieving an agreement that will ratchet
down emissions in a meaningful way and
we have been able to negotiate with
China and unpressed we're the first and
the second largest admit errs emitters
of greenhouse gases an unprecedented
mutual commitment
to reduce our carbon output and that has
set the stage for us to be able to gain
commitments from countries amounting to
eighty percent eighty five percent now
of emissions around the world to make
very concrete national commitments to
reduce their emissions so if we can get
this agreement in Paris and if it is
meaningful and and substantive that will
be a huge step and steps we've taken
domestically to reinforce that are a
critical part as well got it so if I
could pivot a little bit just to an area
that you don't get to talk too much at
least so much about publicly and I think
you know but I know you well enough to
know that you are passionate about some
things that go beyond foreign policy
they think right and there are things
that are important to our nation and one
of the things that you share with me
Susan you know is your passion for sort
of improving equality of opportunity in
this nation and globally and and so when
you think about hot-button issues that
that are like like criminal justice
reform and policing and immigration
health care K through 12 education gay
marriage I mean so many of them relate
to this you know are related to this the
issue of equality of opportunity and
some of these issues you all really
moved the needle on it and within the
context of administration over the last
seven years
some are rising to the top now but I
just I want to get your you know your
point of view not necessarily from the
point of the perspective of the
administration okay because this is not
your lane right get out of mine but
given that you know we're we're here
with members of the New Haven community
and students and professors here at the
University who are ambitious and
idealistic and are tackling some of
these tough issues you know in your mind
you know what are the one or two
critical levers that we should focus on
in our nation to move the needle on
equality of opportunity well
okay how do we okay I'm sorry
okay so can you hear better now thank
you for saying it I wish you'd said it
sooner
thank you thank you these are unusual
contraptions can you hear me yeah okay
sorry so repeat the question so the
question is when you think about you
know addressing equal you know
inequality here in equality of
opportunity in this nation and you can
speak globally if you like you know if
you you know if you were folks in the
crowd if you know what should we what
can we move the needle on what are the
things the levers that we should be
focusing on to to build a nation that as
a that really addresses and moves the
needle on on on equality of opportunity
well I mean Johnny you know this is
something I care deeply about but it's
not an area that I'm expert in I I think
you heard from the introduction of my
background and Johnny's I call him
Johnny by the way some people call him
John that we've taken very different
career paths but we grew up in the same
household with the same values in the
same parents and the same many of the
same I think
motivations and concerns and I think
this is a an area that has United us
John's work is is really about building
ladders for those who have not had
necessarily all of the the privilege and
opportunity that has been that we've
been blessed with and that that many are
blessed with so that they have the
mentorship and the preparation and the
training to go into high-powered
careers and opportunities in business or
management or the nonprofit world but
the theory of John's nonprofit is that
if you catch a young person early on and
give that him or her with all of their
inherent talent the opportunities the
mentorship the training the support to
succeed then the likelihood of their
success goes way up and my own personal
passion that is Johnny said it's not the
focus of my work day-to-day but is
fundamentally an animating motivation is
I believe deeply as many of us do in the
fundamental Worth and equality of every
human being and I believe fundamentally
and this may be part of my experience as
an african-american woman that there is
so much more talent out there than ever
is able to rise to the surface and that
we have not only an obligation and an
interest in nurturing and cultivating
that talent but that as a matter of
national strength and even indeed as a
matter of national security to the
extent that we are not cultivating and
nurturing that talent wherever it may
reside we are we are diminished we are
not firing on all cylinders we're
competing with one hand tied behind our
back
and so I I believe passionately that we
can do better and we have to do better
and that I I think frankly boils down to
what you all would assume and that is
sort of obvious which is education and
starting at the earliest stages at
preschool in early early education
preschool and all the way up through
higher education being able to provide
young people with the the support that
they need and deserve and that means
that education has to be affordable it
has to be of a decent quality it has
be safe and it has to be available to
kids where they come from inner city New
Haven or from you know the wealthiest
suburbs elsewhere and frankly we'd still
have not done in my judgment as a nation
a sufficient job of focusing on that
deficit and investing in the talent that
this nation has and we are one of the
most skilled diverse rich societies in
the world and when I look out
internationally and I think you know how
do we sustain American leadership
through the 21st century and beyond how
do we maximize our inherent strengths
and I don't mean just our military
strength or even our economic strength
but our social and our intellectual
strength and our cultural strength it
necessitates that we take advantage of
this extraordinary fabric that that is
our talented and diverse society and if
we're not doing that adequately not only
we're leaving behind so many but I
really truly believe we are not doing
our we're not fulfilling our potential
as a global leader right right so get
even more personal okay so you're a mom
of two yeah right you have a seventh
grader and you have a son seventh grade
daughter MERIS son in high school was
actually accompanied you here Jake and
and your wife of 23 years that right
okay and you spent a lot of time I mean
you know I've been so impressed by how
you've been able to spend so much time
over the course of last eight years
caring for her father
you know our mom now you know and
finding her you know finding time to do
that so so this is not a question about
work-life balance because I know that's
not you know even a a you know part of a
vocabulary here but but I wanted to you
know I wanted to see if you have any you
know guiding principles around that you
could share with the audience hear that
about how to stay above water and not
let the most important balls drop how do
you approach it how do you know how do
you knowing that it's not perfect
knowing that that you've got to make
tough trade-offs in your personal life
you've you know you've you've kept the
most important I can attest to that
personally I've been really I really
admire you how you figure about it do
that and it comes with trade-offs but
any you know what advice would you have
for the folks here whether they're
undergrad grad students here or folks
who are not students here on on how to
keep the most important balls from
dropping when you're well let me first
of all I'm not trying to blow smoke here
but Johnny has given me a lot of credit
and the fact is we've both we have had
well we've been blessed with two
wonderful parents our father passed away
four and a half years ago our mom is
still alive she I think would have
enjoyed being here today she's in
Washington and her health is fragile and
we have together I think done a pretty
good job of trying to support our
parents and we've succeeded because
we've done it together along with my
husband and and Johnny's wife and our
kids and the answer to your question is
because you know it's a this is teamwork
no one individual can can manage you
know the the challenges of taking care
of kids taking care of family taking
care of self
it does require partners very well
that's oh very well
definitely Mary yeah I've been in you do
extraordinarily blessed to have this the
most wonderful supportive and you know
talented husband you've you've done
very well yourself and and fortunately
everybody likes each other so we really
we have been a team but if I had some
advice I'd say the following first of
all everybody is different every
circumstance is different and I hate
these conversations where you know women
debate whether they lean in lean out you
know you know tell everybody how to
handle their lives my view on this is
everybody its life it's different
everybody's circumstances different
people need to stop telling each other
what to do and just support each other
and recognize that everybody is trying
to make the best choice as they can in
their particular circumstances and
there's no one-size-fits-all formula the
only thing I can say from my vantage
point that has been a valuable principle
for me is that family comes first and
even in a job like mine family comes
first because and your dearest friends
because when everything else falls apart
that's what you've got left you've got
the people you love and the people who
love you and if you ever forget that
then I think you're missing something
fundamental and I just want to say I
mean I've been I've thought a lot about
this in my own life and I've just seen
it modeled in the most extraordinary way
when having had the privilege of working
very closely with Vice President Biden
who has just gone through extraordinary
loss and Matt and in the context of
working you know the second toughest job
in the world and he has been there for
his family his family has been there for
him he was there for Bo just as he was
there for Bo and Hunter early in their
lives when they suffered extraordinary
loss and he is living proof that you can
and you must invest your utmost in the
family even as you take on the most
challenging responsibilities that you
might find whether in government of the
private sector or the nonprofit world so
you know there have been times in my
professional life and personal life
where it's you know we've hit very
painful patches but what is made at all
sustainable and worthwhile is that we've
had each other
and we've had our extended family and
the love and support of our kids and our
parents and our spouses and I think you
know it's a simple truism but I think
sometimes in the rush and the press of
professional life and stress that can
sometimes be forgotten and it should be
alright so before we open it up for
questions I have one last one and is it
builds upon what you said and and it
speaks to you know yeah you've had con
you've had a quite a roller coaster ride
right over the course of the last few
years I mean you you know the great run
at the UN felt like you got a lot done
there
Benghazi came up and got politicized
there the whole Secretary of State stuff
and and now what you talked about some
of things that you've really been
excited about over the course of your
tenure here and as a national security
adviser so there probably lots of people
here today whose parents are worrying
how they will handle adversity when it
comes up how do you you know and handle
setbacks because so many folks here up
at Yale haven't had big setbacks yet and
these are these can be a new frontier
because we've had so much success in
your lives to date and I'm wondering you
know what advice would you have for
these folks about what you draw on when
you have setbacks when you have
adversity well you know when that comes
would it were to you drawn do draw unfit
from family you know do what you'd have
what do you look at what do you do even
when especially when times where you
feel like you you know you may or may
not have done anything to bring that
diversity on yourself
and that's a tough question but it's a
personal question but anything you would
share with the group about how to how to
deal with adversity when it comes well I
think the first answer is the answer I
already gave which is the family and
friends
and the strength that they provide but I
think also the strength has got to come
from inside and I was just speaking very
very personally I have for better or for
worse
I've always known Who I am I've always
known what I believe I've always tried
to do what I do with the utmost
integrity and in intensity and I believe
that you know I know who I am and I also
know who I'm not and when I'm watching a
caricature or a critique of myself that
is painful and personalized I'm able to
I don't want to suggest it I don't feel
the I don't feel offended or I don't
feel hurt in some instances by it but
I'm also able to distinguish between
what I know about myself and who I know
myself to be and what is being said and
there to the extent that I'm able to
understand and maintain that distinction
I can keep a certain distance running
what's harder and I'll tell you that you
know this but I'll just acknowledge it
here the hardest thing for me going
through the period you described in 2012
was not what it felt like for me the
hardest thing was what I saw it do to my
mom and to my daughter
who were in very different ways and
different I mean what was Maris was
fifth grade yeah 11 12 know she's 12 now
she was she was nine it really hit her
very very hard she was old enough to be
able to understand that her mom is being
vilified on the television and hear the
things that were being said and sort of
understand why it was happening but not
really understand that it did what you
see isn't necessarily all that there is
his story and it was it really was
briefly but intensely destabilizing for
her and then my mom who's tough as nails
but has a addiction to cable news just
couldn't turn television off but also it
was driving her absolutely insane and
this after she'd just come out of the
hospital and been through you know
surgery and very difficult recovery and
all this stuff and you know she just was
beside herself and it was the only time
that I was really I hate to say this but
I was glad dad wasn't alive because if a
dad had been alive he would have taken
his shotgun up to Capitol Hill and it
would have been all over grew up in
South Carolina you know you just the
other thing I'd say is that you you keep
working and keep doing what you believe
and in some ways it was great to be at
the UN at the time where the issues that
we were working on and that my fellow
ambassadors cared about were far removed
from the noise in Washington it never it
you it was incredible to me that as UN
ambassador
would have to go before the UN press
corps multiple times a week and make
statements or take questions I never
once at the UN got asked about Benghazi
because they didn't care they was they
they saw it as a manufactured political
story and they wanted to ask about the
issues on the on the UN Agenda come to
Washington it's a little bit different
yeah got okay let's open it up so yeah
why don't you come on up as you will be
much more capable moderator than I look
so how we want to run this she's running
it first I just want to make sure we
give a large round of applause to
ambassador rice
and I want to thank Johnny but encourage
him to keep his day job so I am the
moderator of this QA session and I may
need to moderate up here as well as I
see oh there was a friendly handshake
that just happened I am the master of
Timothy Dwight College I'm Mary Lou and
I'm it's a real pleasure for me to greet
all of you and certainly welcome our two
wonderful guests who shared with us
their remarks and they covered so much
ground and their fireside chat so I
think there's going to be numerous
opportunities to ask questions to follow
up I also want to take the time really
quickly to thank president Sall avait
for his introductory marks thank you for
that so we are gonna open up for
questions right now so please go ahead
and line up either two microphones right
here and just be in a very orderly
fashion and we'll alternate between the
two microphones I'm seeing two very
large lines forming and we will not be
able to get through all of the questions
I already apologizing to the people in
the back so I will just say once you ask
your question please step aside from the
microphone and let's let our wonderful
guests respond so let's start on the
side I am live in Ukraine I've done so
for the past 25 years I'd like to ask
you your view on the situation in
Ukraine with reference to two things in
particular first do the violations of
the Budapest treaty fundamentally
undermine nuclear non-proliferation for
the future and second can the US with
Japan which I believe would be favorable
to this I know it would be and EU help
to get the world - amiga political risk
insurance program going for Ukraine
again so that there can be an investment
from the rest of the world you've done a
fine job with OPEC but a lot of the
world that was investing Ukraine has
stopped and it's produced a catastrophic
25 percent decline in the GDP and this
wasn't caused by Ukraine it was caused
by Ukraine's reliance on the security
assurances
of the budapest treaty based on which
you gave up five thousand nuclear
weapons so can can the United States
help with us well certainly we can and
we are working to help Ukraine in many
different ways with its economic
recovery
just yesterday just yesterday I was
saying we're we are working to help
Ukraine in various ways including with
its economic recovery just yesterday in
Kiev we announced the third one billion
dollar US government loan guarantee for
the government in Kiev we are providing
technical assistance we're providing
military aid we're providing various
forms of security and economic support
to the government and the loan
guarantees of course are not the the sum
total of our economic assistance but
they're a part and parcel we've also
been very active with Europe and the
international financial institutions to
try to provide the support that Ukraine
is now receiving through the
international financial institutions so
we are very much trying to support
economic recovery in Ukraine and and its
independence from its its former
dependence on on Russia and the East so
there is there is there have been some
creative ideas in and you may be
referring to some of the ideas that
George Soros has talked about correct
and these are ones that we have looked
at very carefully I've spoken myself to
mr. Soros about this as many of my
colleagues including secretary Lew his
idea relies on a mechanism within the
European Union and their ability to
activate a mechanism that could leverage
additional funds and unfortunately there
are a number of complexities with it but
the principle one being that the
Europeans have not been interested in
pursuing that object his way of doing it
is not the only way there are other ways
I was a lawyer in the private sector
there for 25 years we have a lot of
pines that would like to come in and
make a contribution to the economy
private sector has been forgotten he is
correct without political risk insurance
when he gets to board approval level
companies are afraid with that they will
go forward with the plans they would
like to implement and I personally have
actually my law firm a couple of billion
dollars of investment that is presently
frozen they could be unblocked with
political risk insurance at the mEagle
level as has been done for the West Bank
in Gaza that would work sources
mechanism probably doesn't well I
appreciate that and I'll look into it
thank you thank you yes this gentleman
here thank you ambassador rice and
brother you can call him Johnny it was
very interesting to hear the personal
side to know that behind that that very
informative government figure that you
are that there is a very personal side
that's very important I want to my
question has to do with Syria but very
quickly regarding this gentleman Ukraine
we represent a consortium of students
all over the world and many of them are
in Ukraine and they asked me to ask you
one question or to let you know one
thing and that they are very concerned
about the fact that the general
prosecutor in Ukraine they feel is
corrupt and it's not really doing making
any progress in terms of judicial reform
in terms of really reforming the
judiciary and reforming and getting rid
of a lot of government figures and this
is what they feel and they're just
wondering if the United States could
exert some kind of leverage or at least
look into the fact that this general
prosecutor is is very much not on the
side of Ukraine citizenry but that my
main question has to do with seer
and what I consider is a not a no-fly
zone but a buffer zone and the fact that
we also deal with Russian students and
they all seem to be feel that the
Russian government might be very
amenable to considering the
establishment of a buffer zone so that
refugees instead of having to cross the
Mediterranean could could rest or be
settled in this zone with obviously
there's a lot of you know there's a lot
of problems with that I realize there's
there's costs and then there's
possibility of conflict but if the
Russian government is willing to support
this and they feel it will because the
refugees a lot of these refugees or a
lot of these terrorists could a lot of
jihadists could be part of the refugees
and going back to Russia so that I'm
wondering why the United States
government has not pursued or at least
outwardly pursued the establishment more
of a buffer zone in Syria thank you very
much well thank you for the question
it's a it's a topical one we have at
various points during the course of the
crisis in Syria
weighed the merits and risks of various
forms of zones as we shorthand them
no-fly zones safe zones on the ground
where civilians could be protected I
think that's what you mean and then
we've also looked at something that
we've termed a buffer zone which is not
necessarily a safe zone with protection
for civilians on the ground but some
zone meant to be a bulwark so that
people and weapons and other malicious
flows of goods and and the light can't
continue to occur in all honesty these
are options that that we continue to
examine we have not ruled out any of
them
you know in a formal or permanent way
but we've looked at them very very
closely including again very recently
and they are fraught with real
challenges and difficulties they are
incredibly resource intensive to secure
so take your model of let me call it a
safe zone on let's say the northern or
southern border within Syria and either
a budding turkey or a budding Jordan
where theoretically civilians might be
protected to to enforce a safe zone
effectively you not only need planes in
the air and the planes in the air are
complicated because the threat that most
of the the most proximate danger to
civilians is in fact not fixed-wing
aircraft it's helicopters dropping
barrel bombs that are harder to deal
with in the context of an air cap and
then it's on the ground where you need
literally tens of thousands of troops to
hold and clear that territory where
those troops would come from whether
weighing our interests you would use our
air power and our forces to protect
folks on the ground and clearing out
territory or whether you would use them
to go after Israel because they are not
the same mission is one of the tricky
questions that policymakers have to
weigh a trade-off where if we were to
employ additional resources would they
best be utilized a humanitarian mission
which is the one you're describing is
not it's not the same as a counter-isil
mission in the current context there may
be a point when they allied but they
don't at the moment and then you you
have the question of to what extent is
that actually improve conditions on the
ground
the major border crossings are open to
humanitarian aid the aid is flowing so
particularly into the areas near the
border that we're talking about so the
incremental benefit to civilians are
actual humanitarian experts do not think
is is very significant and there's a
real question as to whether the
establishment of these zones would draw
people back in or actually cause them to
flee for fear that they're going to be
trapped in these zones where they'd
rather have freedom of movement
internally or externally so there
there's a huge number of complexities
associated with this which is not to say
these are options that are off the table
but we are digging into them very deeply
and they are not as simple and obvious
solutions as you might hear if by
turning on you know CNN and listening to
to what the pundits are saying thank you
and over here I sorry I have laryngitis
but I didn't want to pass up this
opportunity to ask your question it may
be for both of you one is as a woman of
color you're constantly in international
settings where you are maybe the only
woman in the room
or the only african-american ring how
you handle yourself in those situations
where you might find sexism or some type
of discrimination against you because of
who you are and the other part of my
question is I teach at an inner-city
high school here in New Haven at Hill
House and it may be more towards you
Tony what do you think we can do at the
local level to help our kids for to
experience things like this to expose
them to international because they think
very small they think very locally and
to get them to think more outside of New
Haven or their particular situations and
contribute like you were talking about
at the end about there are so many
resources that we don't tap for whatever
reason
that America might be losing out on the
potential that we have and who knows you
know maybe the person who has a cure for
cancer is a high school student in Hill
House but they may not have the same
opportunities that other have so if you
could address that okay did you all hear
the question
so the one was directed to me and one
was directed to Johnny the one directed
to me was I hope I don't do it miss
justice but essentially as an
african-american woman finding herself
in various international settings how do
I deal with some being the only one or
being certainly one a few and have I
faced you know discrimination and and
the like and I I think the answer is you
know obviously there there some
circumstances where I may be the only
woman in the room or the only person of
color but I'm representing the United
States of America and I have found that
when when I show up in whatever role I'm
in even when I was in far more junior
roles as a representative the United
States of America people primarily dealt
with me on that basis and I can't
pretend that there have been occasions
when you know I people have made flip
comments or you know been somewhat
condescending but for the most part they
don't have the the space or the ability
to to do that or to dwell on it because
they know at the end of the day that
they have to deal for better or for
worse with whatever the United States
government is coming or saying or doing
and that's the basis on which I have
found that that I'm interacting on most
if not all occasions and so I to a great
extent have not found that to be an
impediment
far more of an impediment frankly but
still overridden by this fact that I was
representing the US government was when
I was 32 years old and the Assistant
Secretary of State for African affairs
and often the senior American official
going around representing the United
States and it was my youth rather than
my gender or my race that was most
noticed and still not something that at
the end of the day got in the way of my
doing my job I quickly say of relative
to Hill House sure you know it's the
easy answer is to to expose your
students you know to what's happening
over here yelled and get them over here
and invited to things like this and so
forth I think that's part of it I'm sure
we can do more of that but I also think
the heart the type of thing and the
thing we need do more of is take the
Yale over to them makes you know and and
and meet them where they are you know I
just just coincidentally when I was a
student here I started a you know get my
actually my first exposure to have to
kind of my first bug in excitement
around mentoring and and and the social
sector actually started a program over
at Hill House high school this is back
in the 80s that was called young Men's
Leadership Forum and we took we brought
a bunch of Yale students over to to Hill
house every week and we did study skills
and mentoring we did you know a lot of
work on the ground in the classrooms
with those students and just to provide
most of whom were were teenage fathers
okay and we just met them where they
were and we you know we helped and we
built relationships and and we were
there you know in their house and I
think that really made a difference the
other thing we did which is sort of that
that I think you could argue we may be
is is the kind of thing we could do more
of but just as a fun entrepreneurial
thing you know for those of you don't
know at least back then Hill House had a
great basketball tradition and and they
would when they would play Wilbur cross
here they would have more people
Payne Whitney Jim then we would have
when we were flying hail of the Yale
basketball team and so so they thought
they were real good basketball so I
brought my no I was on the basketball
team here we went over to Hill House and
play it brought and when we were seniors
played a game in their gym Yale varsity
basketball versus them and and we had
them introduce it speak to we had
speakers it was a fantastic sort of
community event and brought in and built
a lot of bridges things like that I mean
that's way you know many many years ago
but it's an example of things that we
can do more of and I'm sure we're doing
a lot of the much already that Peter
could speak to but figuring out ways to
bring the best of Yale to them in
addition to thinking about exposure
around them coming to us right so who
won the game we killed them yes and yes
there are so Tim Shriver who's you know
chairman Special Olympics was a teacher
over it will over at Hill House then and
and he will attest he was that my
partner in building this initiative and
with it that was very accessible and and
not only do we win but are we wasn't me
in this case but one of our one of my
teammates won the dunk contest against
those guys okay so it was it was an
eye-opening moment for how students yes
over here please
so there's a little over a year left in
President Obama's term and I'm just
wondering looking back and even a little
bit forward is there such a thing as an
Obama doctrine anything resembling that
and if that is the case is there
something is there a rice doctrine the
rights to action would have to be the
Obama doctrine for now for the next 15
months no you know we've really
refrained from from trying to distill
our approach into a doctrine I think if
you understand the way President Obama
approaches foreign policy and national
security
he is both principled and pragmatic and
he would reject as a matter of
intellectual point of view but also as a
matter of practice a one-size-fits-all
approach and so no we don't have a
doctrine what we what he would say and
what he deeply believes is that American
leadership is necessary and
indispensable that it can be and must be
a force for progress and for good but
that there are limits to what even the
most powerful nation on the planet can
accomplish for other people in their own
countries at the end of the day whether
it's political transformation or
economic growth or or even conflict
resolution there are vital contributions
that the United States and others in the
international community now typically
with American leadership can bring to
bear but at the end of the day there are
certain fundamentals that have to be
accomplished by and for the people of a
given country or a given region whether
it's fighting corruption cronyism
insisting on respect for human rights
the outside world can do a great deal to
call attention and demand certain
standards and performance but the end of
the day it will not last and it will not
be something that is fundamentally
enduring unless it is owned by the local
population and that's in many ways the
challenge we're facing in Syria and Iraq
it's the challenge we're facing in
Afghanistan it's the challenge that you
could argue is is at the root of many of
the most difficult global problems that
we are wrestling with
Jackie hi thank you so much first of all
for sharing your insights with us op
students in the room and we're figuring
out what specials need to be and how and
if we want those to relate to our
careers after education so I was just
wondering since you hold degrees in
different disciplines if you could talk
about the values and interests that took
you from there to where you are today I
wish I could tell you that you know
there was a linear path between I was a
history major Johnny
studied Latin American Studies and then
I went on and did international
relations I don't think so my piece of
advice if I have one is very simple and
that's to follow your passion do
whatever it is that motivates you and
excites you whether you think it's going
to get you a good job coming out of
college or not do what you find
fascinating and motivating and that's
what you're going to be good at and
that's what will take you to the next
and the next exciting thing I never
anticipated when I was an undergraduate
at Stanford that I would be in a career
in international affairs much less as a
national security advisor or UN
ambassador that was not I was going to
be a civil rights lawyer or you know a
community activist that's sort of how I
thought of my future and if I ever got a
home state that had voting rights as
opposed to the District of Columbia
where I grew up I thought maybe I might
run for public office and I've ended up
in a completely different place and but
the one thing I have done is follow my
heart and my head and do things that I
love to do and that's never led me
astray so that's what I would say one
thing I'll add that is while you're
following your passion work really hard
at this stage of your career to figure
out where what your genius gifts are
where you could be top ten top twenty
percent in your peer group what you do
best and what that translates into from
a career standpoint because it's great
to be focused on stuff
that you love you know if you want to
you know I always share a story beat
folks I want to you know I want to be
recording artists but you better be able
to sing if you can't sing I don't care
how passion you are about music make
money doing that right so focus on you
know that combined with people who get
the farthest people who realize their
potential we've found have they they
combine this that sweet spot that Lane
which is what you're passionate about
and what you're you know where your
genius gifts are and because what you
need to focus on at this stage early on
is being a high performer and if you're
a hypersphere more likely behind forever
if your focus on what your passion about
but you're most likely high performer if
you're really good at what you're doing
and being high pourable proposition you
develop the relationships that you will
that will really catapult your career
that i think everyone here who's more
you know tenure in their career could
speak to about how important that is so
I'm afraid we're actually out of time so
I feel very badly for these you too lot
your two lines that waited so patiently
can we please give ambassador rice and
John rice another round
thank you
you
you